hello there and good morning it is 7am
this is sky news breakfast the race for
number 10 is down to the final five the
former chancellor richie sunak is still
in the lead but his closest rival penny
morden is not far behind she's made the
most gains after two rounds of voting
well that leaves liz trust in third
place and battling for the backing of
the right of the party but in a boost to
her campaign the former contender swella
bravo manic gave the foreign secretary
her support after she got knocked out in
yesterday's ballots now on the programme
this morning we'll hear from three
conservative mps who've planted their
flags in different contenders camps and
we'll get the latest view on all of this
the labour party's lucy powell it is
friday the 15th of july
five candidates remain in the race 4pm
with rishi sunak still on top but penny
mordant continuing to gain ground
liz trust still trails in third but her
campaign has been given a boost as suela
babaman offers her support
another two days of rail strikes
announced for august in a dispute over
jobs pay and working conditions
extreme heat warning temperatures in
parts of the uk could jump 10 degrees in
the coming days with warnings hospitals
could face a surge in demand
the government is told to apologize to
tens of thousands of unmarried mothers
who had their babies forcibly taken away
for adoption
you're being judged about something you
didn't do
i didn't give him up
i didn't give him away
i'm in sri lanka where the president's
resignation has been officially
announced and accepted by the country's
speaker
and in ukraine president zielenski
brands a russian missile attack which
left 23 people dead in a city close to
kiev as an act of open terrorism
and also this morning with england off
to a great start to the women's euros
2022 i'll be joined by lionesses legend
kelly smith
and the campaign for more awareness
about drinks biking is launched today
i'll be joined by miss united kingdom
clara george
[Music]
hello and thank you for being with us
and then there were five the former
chancellor richie sunak has come out on
top again in the second round of voting
in the tory leadership election but the
momentum still seems to be worth penny
mordant now liz trust remains in third
place in a boost to her campaign last
night swella braverman the and the
prominent brexiter lord frost are
calling for her to get the top job now
over the next few days the romanian
candidates will go head to head in a
series of televised debates starting
tonight let's take a closer look at the
results of yesterday's votes rishi
sooner got 101 votes that's up 13 from
round one 120 is the number needed to
guarantee a spot in the runoff
ponymorden has gained an extra 16 from
the last round she's now on 83.
liz trust and kemi badanok remain third
and fourth respectively the foreign
secretary getting 64 votes the former
equalities minister 49.
tom tugandatz is last having actually
lost the support of five mps sweller
bravo men as we've been saying though
was ejected from the race securing just
27 votes
so here is how it all works from here
the conservative mps will vote again on
monday in the third round of secret
ballots the candidate with the fewest
votes will be eliminated from the
contest
there'll be further ballots next week as
necessary until just two candidates
remain the whole party membership will
then be balloted on the final two with
the new party leader and our new prime
minister being named on the 5th of
september
well i'm joined now by the conservative
mp verb beijing stoke and the former
culture secretary dame maria miller who
is backing penny mordont dame maria
miller thank you very much for being
with us and good morning to you just
first off why are you backing penny
well i'm backing penny mordant because
she really is the candidate that reaches
out effectively to all
sectors of the conservative party and we
see that in parliament and the support
that she's had in the first two rounds
but also around the country and uh you
will have seen the polling that's been
done
amongst our grassroots membership and
penny really does uh reach every part of
the party she's got the experience
that's needed um having been a minister
in many different
departments over the last five or six
years and i think she brings that fresh
change
that we really want in this government
to make sure that we can deliver on the
manifesto that we were elected on in
2019.
i mean you say that she reaches every
part of the party it's not every part is
it you'll have seen the newspapers this
morning lord frost's saying that she was
ineffective and that she didn't master
the detail of brexit i mean is he wrong
i think he is uh based on my experience
of working with penny for more than a
decade i've seen her to be a very
effective campaigner and although i'm a
remain in myself or was at the
time of the referendum
she really is one of the leading
proponents of brexit and was throughout
the campaign obviously
lord frost decided to leave the
government and is now joining this
debate from outside and people will
listen to his views but my experience
and i have to say the experience of
colleagues in parliament don't really
reflect his comments what we want to see
is somebody who's going to bring that
fresh start
and really invigorate our party as we
deliver on what is a really important
manifesto
now um she's also coming for some
criticism as you will know on the issue
of uh trans rights um can you just try
and clear this up first this morning
there's been some disagreement and some
perhaps misunderstanding exactly where
uh penny morgan stands on that uh why
has she felt the need to change her
position on what a woman is
penny hasn't changed her position on any
aspects of equalities and obviously she
was an equality as minister
and she is very
clear that she supports the two main
issues in this area which is making sure
that we have protected spaces for women
which is in law um and making sure that
there's fairness when it comes to
uh sporting competitions and that
the sporting bodies take very clear
account of the impact of trans issues on
the way that their
sport is performed those are the main
issues she's very clear on it and i i
don't think this really
something just so so fundamental to some
people's lives and and so sensitive is
really something that's appropriate for
a a leadership battle um it should be
outside of politics
so she didn't she most misspoke in
parliament when she said that trans
women are women because she's now seems
to draw a distinction between biological
women and trans women
and so when penny was a minister she was
stating what the law is and the law is
absolutely as you've just said trans
women are women
if if any other candidate is deciding to
to have a change in the law uh
then then they need to make that clear
but penny was obviously just stating
exactly what the law is and that's what
ministers have to do but i think she's
made it very clear and i think this is
important uh that this is a sensitive
issue and a difficult issue um and i
believe like many areas of equalities
it's not really an issue that should be
part of the political fray
we should put these things uh above
politics because you know the way people
live their lives whether they're gay
whether they're
straight their sexuality their gender is
quite fundamental and i don't think it
really deserves to be dealt with in the
context of the cut and thrust of a um a
fast-moving leadership context uh
contests this needs to be about the
things that really
matter to the people of this country
right now which is the cost of living
the war in ukraine you know things that
penny has policies on and experience in
having been
an international development secretary
and the defense secretary and having
served in her majesty's armed forces um
penny has the credentials to deliver on
this and those are the things she's
focusing on well i'm glad you brought up
the real issues that people are facing
uh
in parts of the country i mean why have
we not heard anything from um penny
mordant about efforts to tackle the nhs
backlog that is a situation that perhaps
is going to get worse in the coming days
well penny like i think probably all uh
candidates will be making sure that uh
when she takes over as prime minister
that she continues the work that's
already in train i mean
contenders and and uh for the leadership
can't come in and uh change every aspect
of the way government runs and indeed
those who are already ministers
presumably uh feel that the policies are
strong and i i do think that the
government's already set out very
clearly how they're going to be tackling
uh the backlog of uh
that's resulted from the kovic crisis
and indeed many billions of pounds extra
has gone into the nhs what we now need
is a leader who can put a team of people
in place
the best people uh to be able to make
sure
that those policies are practiced um and
and so that's why it's so important to
have somebody who who isn't just talking
about themselves but is talking about
having a team of strong
and effective individuals in the cabinet
to make sure that issues like the one
you've just raised are tackled swiftly
and will she keep the the same team in
place
and and where does she stand on perhaps
uh holding a general election the
idea is that penny modern is a clear
start so isn't she the best place to
perhaps hold a general election and get
a uh mandate of her own
uh penny's been very clear and
particularly at the launch of her
campaign earlier this week uh the the
thing that the country needs now is some
continuity some stability in government
um a fresh start to delivering on a
manifesto that is only uh two and a half
years ago that uh was uh agreed on by
the electorate at the ballot box so we
need some stability uh we don't believe
that what's needed now is a general
election there is a clear mandate there
um and when it comes to the team of
people that will be around around her
around the cabinet table obviously
that's something for the prime minister
and
what do you uh how would you answer the
charge that uh penny morning seems to
sort of represent for for people
everything that they want but actually
doesn't have a clear position on where
she stands on a number of issues how do
you answer that charge because that is a
question that's being leveled against
penny at the moment
i think when you're looking at a
leadership campaign like this you're
looking for the principles and the
values of the individual you know all of
us as conservative members of parliament
when we stood in december 2019 stood on
a manifesto
this leadership change
won't change that manifesto and those
commitments though of course there'll be
some fresh new ideas coming coming
forward and penny's already announced
and it really in reaction to the the
most important issue facing people at
the moment which is the cost of living
crisis that she would look at cutting
vat duty in half
on petra the petrol pumps and and that's
just one of the examples of the way we
need to develop policies of the
government to uh respond to
the political reality of the that people
face today um but ultimately you know
this is about a leadership change to get
a fresh and new invigorated leader in
place and that's why i'm supporting
penny mordant because she has that broad
approach and and what we would call a
one nation conservative
and penny seconds now i mean how
concerned is she in the campaign of
these sort of dirty tricks dark hearts
that may be in uh places at the moment
or may well be put in train to try and
make sure that she doesn't get that
second spot in any runoff
i i think you've seen in each of the
rounds of the leadership contest uh that
penny's
support amongst members of parliament
has grown and and that's the same
throughout the country and all of the
research that's coming out and the uh
the polling that's being done is showing
that her uh her support her support base
is growing um throughout the united
kingdom um and you know this this uh
leadership uh contest is run along a set
of lines and uh you know i think people
will want it to be a positive campaign
we're you know we're colleagues together
we're not uh we're not
opposing each other in in a fundamental
political sense it is just about getting
a new leader and i hope that it stays a
positive campaign and certainly
that's penny's style that's why i'm
supporting her she's got the sort of
integrity and the sort of positive
approach to politics which i think
brings a fresh approach and and i think
a kind of politics as well which i think
people watching this morning probably
would welcome
some of the remaining candidates who do
you think penny stands the best chance
against in any runoff
look all of my colleagues who are
standing for election are just that
colleagues and i
you know i i i i think all of them have
got very strong you must have a
preference um
um i i think that the figures would show
that the problem probably the person who
is you know has got the strongest
support in the parliamentary party is
rishi sunaka's a very high profile
position in being chancellor i it's not
really about
who you're going to most likely win i i
want the best person to run our country
um i believe that's penny mordant and
that's why i'm supporting her and will
continue to do so throughout the next uh
few days
so if she was to win and uh and then
start facing kirsten how do you think
she would do in some of those uh red
wall seats in the midlands and in the
north where of course it's
massively important that the
conservatives hold on to those suits
uh well as you know there's been quite a
lot of polling that's been done in the
last week to show that penny
is the most effective conservative
politician against uh against the labour
party and uh and i understand that
labour fear penny the most uh but that's
really not what this contest is about is
about having
the best person to run the country now
and then yes go on and fight a general
election um and you know penny's support
is very broad uh me from me perhaps uh
very much a centrist in our party all
the way to somebody like david davis who
is is known to be somebody championing
free speech
perhaps uh a little more to the right
and uh i think it's that ability to be
able to bring people together uh which
will be will make her a winning formula
um against others in a general election
okay damian marie will leave it there
thank you very much for your time this
morning maria miller supporting penny
mordent full conservative leader thank
you for your time
okay let me just remind you of a special
program we have coming up here next week
here on sky news we're going to be
hosting a live television debate with
those who are vying to be the next
leader of the conservative party and of
course the country's next prime minister
the debates will be held on tuesday at 8
00 pm now the change of date follows
consultation with the candidates and the
conservative party's 1922
committee you can be part of the
audience for the debate now to get
involved and to apply to put your
questions to the candidates email news
debates at sky dot u k that's sky news
debate the 19th of july and you can take
part by emailing the address that you
see on your screen right now
okay let's take a look at the morning's
newspapers now we'll start with the
front page of the times which reports on
liz trusts winning the support of swella
braverman and the nhs is bracing for a
surge in patients as a result of next
week's heat wave
the telegraph has a piece from the
former chief brexit negotiator lord
frost urging kemi badanok to stand aside
so that liz trust can have a clear run
into the final two
the ir reports on the way rivals have
turned on penny mordent
the male's headline as you can see more
than under the microscope
cinema vein on the front of the express
knives out for penny they say not up to
the job say rivals the express is front
page the metro though points to her
strong showing pennies in heaven their
headline
on the daily mirror warns that
temperatures could hit 40 degrees next
week
the sun reports that the footballer
jamie vardy and his wife rebecca have
been affected by wildfires in portugal
the guardian has reported that the
environment agency is calling for water
company bosses to be jailed over high
pollution levels
the financial times reports on falling
incomes of two major u.s banks and
beneath the fold the criticism of
heathrow's cap on flights coming from
emirates airlines armageddon is on the
front page of the ft not like them and
the star
tells us that the master chef presenter
john terrod believes that he's a
werewolf because that's one of the
reasons he gets
grumpier when there is a full moon okay
excellent news
fantastic stuff still to come on the
program this morning as the race for the
conservative party leadership hots up
i'll be joined by the mp richard holden
who is backing former chancellor which
is
i'll then be speaking to the director of
orthodox conservatives about what they
and other grassroots groups want from a
new leader
and in the next hour we'll get the view
from the labour party when we speak to
the shadow culture secretary lucy powell
[Music]
well the union of rail maritime and
transport workers has announced two
further days of rail strikes in august
40 000 workers across network rail and
14 train operators will walk out on the
18th and 20th of august in the ongoing
row over jobs pay and conditions
now you kind of fails to have noticed
that it has been very hot lately and
it's going to get even hotter
temperatures are expected to rise by
another 10 degrees in much of england
over the coming days with a warning that
it could increase the strain on
hospitals and trained services the nshs
is facing a surge in demand with wait
times for ambulances in june at 51
minutes
well the rare amber warning for extreme
heat is in place for much of england and
wales for sunday monday and tuesday with
temperatures likely to peak in excess of
35 degrees
well in europe temperatures in spain
have topped 40 degrees seville has
become the first city in the world to
categorize and name its heat waves
experts there hope this could save lives
by raising awareness of the dangers of
extreme heat
parts of northern italy saw highs of 42
degrees worsening the severe drought
which has already dried up the po river
valley the italian parliament won a
third of agricultural production is now
at risk and the government has declared
a state of emergency in several northern
regions
now a cross-party group of mps has
called on the governments to issue a
formal apology to unmarried mothers who
had their babies taken for adoption in
the 50s 60s and 70s in a report that's
been published today the joint committee
on human rights say the government is
responsible for the pain and suffering
caused by public institutions that force
mothers into unwanted adoption
you're being judged about something you
didn't do i didn't give him up i didn't
give him away it is about control
it's all about control
it was they said for the best
the greater good
forced adoption the only choice for an
unmarried pregnant teenager shamed in
the post-war era
anne had barely held her baby son before
a nurse had taken him away
but her trauma didn't end there
you'll never see him again
and now you can come with me
and took me into this
really cold bathroom and
made sure i was in the bath and she
grabbed my breast and started to express
milk
because she said you won't need this
i knew then
that i had no rights at all
the injustice drove and to regain
control
this could never happen again
so she became a nurse
gear changing to a member of parliament
promoted to cabinet health minister
under gordon brown
all this time she had felt so alone
but the issue was far from isolated
185 000 newborns were also forcibly
separated from their parents
and now like many others she wants
closure
an apology and bespoke support from the
system that let it happen
a report released today from a human
rights committee says those at the helm
of power their ultimate responsibility
for the heartbreak faced by thousands of
unmarried mothers
i think having endured a lifetime of
being blamed a lifetime of secrecy and
shame an apology that says clearly and
unambiguously no no you didn't do
anything wrong wrong was done to you
they say that that will be very
important for them and important too to
their children the government says it
has the deepest sympathy for those lycan
impacted by false adoption
and says while it cannot undo the past
its legislation and practice has since
improved
ann's past can't be rewritten but she's
since made up for lost time reuniting
with her son in 1996.
she's now almost complete
it's a really big thing that they can
give us back our respect
chowdhury sky news
okay let's take a look at some of
today's other news now and a u.s
government watchdog has alleged that
emails and texts sent around the time of
the january 6th capital riots were
deleted
by the u.s secret service the messages
had been requested by officials
investigating the riots but it's claimed
they were deleted as part of what the
watchdog calls a device replacement
program the secret service has rejected
the claims as categorically false
ivana trump the first wife of former u.s
president donald trump has died at a
home in new york at the age of 73. a
statement from her family reads our
mother was an incredible woman a force
in business a world-class athlete a
radiant beauty and caring mother and
friend
italy's president has rejected the
resignation of prime minister mario
draghi instead he asks the pm to see if
he can find a majority in parliament
willing to support him mr draghi offered
his resignation after a party in his
ruling coalition the five-star movement
didn't support a key government bill
the oil company shell has warned europe
may need to ration energy supplies
during the winter due to declining
natural gas supply as russia restricts
flow european countries have scrambled
in recent months to fill natural gas
storage for winter as a result prices
have shot up
well let's go to sri lanka now where the
president's resignation has been
officially announced and accepted by the
country's parliament this follows weeks
of course of mass protests against the
government let's bring in nicole johnson
who is in the sri lankan capital colombo
for us this morning uh nicole i believe
uh nicole can you uh just tell us what's
the situation like in the city right now
they've finally
had the uh resignation of mr rajapaksa
[Music]
yes it's a real turning point in sri
lankan politics people have been waiting
for days for this official resignation
to come through and now i've got a buyer
rajapaksa is not only out of the country
but out of a job on the streets here
behind me though in the center of the
protest camp you almost wouldn't know it
it's so quiet there's been no mass
celebrations at all it seems that many
people are so exhausted by the whole
process by the political back and
forwards that they're just waiting to
see
what transpires over the next few days
today we're expecting that the prime
minister will be sworn in as the interim
president parliament has decided that it
will meet on saturday to try and form a
unity government all of this leading up
to presidential elections elected by the
parliament on the 20th
of this month so that's where we're at
at the moment at the same time the
economic crisis here is as bad as ever
sri lanka is broke it has no foreign
currency left driving around the city
it's cues after cues
people lining up for petrol
for cooking gas for food
people don't have enough to eat
the protesters though say that their
struggle is not over they're concerned
that the prime minister about to become
interim presidents reynold wick
remasinga could end up running for
president they see him as a loyalist of
the rajapaksa family and they will not
accept him in a position in the
government so we'll have to wait and see
how that plays out but on thursday those
protesters pulled out of those
government buildings that they had been
occupying for the last few days
including their main prize the
presidential palace so for now things on
the street are very calm but it's an
uncertain environment that we're in here
politically in sri lanka at least for
the next week
certainly is okay nicole for now in
colombo do appreciate that thank you
now if you uh scan the qr code that
you're going to see on your screen right
now there it is you can listen to the
latest episode of our sky news daily
podcast now in this one our
international affairs editor dominic
wagon looks at the situation in sri
lanka and speaks to nicole and a former
adviser to the sri lankan government
michelle brooks you can subscribe to sky
news daily wherever you get your
podcasts
ukraine's president has accused russia
of an open act of terrorism after a
missile attack on a city close to kiev
23 people including three children were
killed in venezia a city not far a city
far away sorry from the front line of
the don bass now the moment that the
missiles hit the city's busy central
square was captured on a security camera
you can see it there people knocked off
their feet by the blasts
and then running for cover
now later on in the program i'll be
speaking to iho zakovska he's one of
president vladimir zelinski's advisers
of asking all about where the war in
ukraine is going right now okay let's
take a look at what the weather has in
store for the next couple of days
warm memories wherever you
[Music]
go the weather sponsored by qatar
airways
it's a bit cooler now but as i said it
will become very very hot early next
week the meta office has issued a rare
amber warning for extreme heat that
covers much of england and wales on
sunday monday and tuesday for now it's
sunny across southern britain but
there's more cloud elsewhere giving
outbreaks of rain mainly across scotland
that rain will become more showery
during the morning as it spreads into
southern parts but southern britain will
stay dry despite cloud increasing
meanwhile ireland northern ireland and
northern scotland will turn drier and
brighter temperatures will be much like
yesterday's
the afternoon brings with it more
widespread sunshine as rain becomes
mainly confined to northeast england
that rain is going to fade to leave a
mostly dry and clear night but more rain
will reach the far north later it'll be
cooler than recently with some fog
patches
let's look at saturday now and that is
going to be mostly sunny but northern
scotland will see some further spells of
rain it will feel warmer too it's
warming up isn't it sunday we'll see the
heat building but the highest
temperatures are likely to be early next
week
the weather sponsored by qatar airworks
all right let's show you a bit of video
here which is a a bit of a great escape
drone footage just captured the moment
that seal tried to get away from being
eaten by a pod of orcas by hiding in of
all places a muscle farm well the video
shows the mammal hiding between two
lines of muscle ropes at grenovae north
of lowik in shetland
the video is being studied by people who
wants to find out more about the impact
that man-made structures
can have on marine life
now
the seal got away we're not sure what
happen dinner but probably muscles
all right
we're not sure still to come on sky news
breakfast we'll have more on the race to
become the next prime minister as i'm
joined by one conservative mp who is
bash backing rishi sumac
[Music]
the race is on the contestants who would
be the next prime minister are
finalizing their pitches the prize to
become the next leader of the
conservative party and grab the keys to
the most famous door in the world join
me k burley as they go head to head live
on sky news that's the battle for number
10 live on tuesday night at 8 on sky
news on our app online and our social
media channels
hello and welcome back you're watching
sky news breakfast the union of rail
maritime and transport workers has
announced two further days of rail
strikes to be held in august let's bring
in our reporter matthew thompson who's
at marlon station in central london for
us this morning matthew good morning to
you so what's the latest we understand
on these strikes
good morning kamali well look it's fast
becoming a summer of discontent we've
got two more strike dates announced this
august by the rmt union the largest uh
rail union on the 18th and the 20th of
august and that adds to dates for
strikes already scheduled by the rmt
unit on the 27th of july and also a
strike date by the as left the train
drivers union on the 30th of july and
both of those dates
happen to coincide with the commonwealth
games which is of course taking place in
birmingham and also with the beginning
of the football season the government
says that that is clearly done on
purpose to try and maximize disruption
so that's the when what about the why
well it's the same dispute that brought
the uk's railways to a standstill last
month it's about in large part pay the
rmt wants
a pay settlement that reflects the cost
of living crisis it's about job cuts
network rail has said it plans to cut
around 2 000 jobs although it insists uh
none of those will be compulsory
redundancies and that's in part because
of the financial burden of the pandemic
as we know
the drop in passenger numbers of the
pandemic
hasn't even recovered at this point and
that's left a black hole in the finances
of lots of transport companies but it's
also network rail says about
modernization they want as an exchange
for uh pay offers
the unions to accept modernizing
conditions uh in exchange now the rmt
has said that network rail's latest
offer of five percent is a paltry sum
and is a real terms pay cut and the
truth of the matter is the main remains
a large uh distance between the two
parties positions and the result of that
i'm afraid is a likely summer of
disruption on the uk's rail networks
okay matthew for now thank you for that
now more on our top story the race for
the tory party leadership in the last
hour i spoke to the conservative mp and
former culture secretary that's dame
maria miller who insisted that her pick
for the top job penny mordant is up to
it the former cultural secretary said
that the prominent brexiter lord frost
was wrong to suggest that the former
defense secretary wasn't always
accountable during her time in
government
based on my experience of working with
penny for more than a decade i've seen
her to be a very effective campaigner
and although i'm a remainder myself or
was at the uh time of the uh referendum
uh she really is one of the leading uh
proponents of brexit and was throughout
the campaign obviously uh lord frost
decided to leave the government and is
now joining this debate from outside and
people will listen to his views but my
experience and i have to say the
experience of colleagues in parliament
don't really reflect his comments um
what we want to see is somebody who's
going to bring that fresh start
and really invigorate our party as we
deliver on what is a really important
manifesto
well for more on the race to lead the
conservative party i'm joined now by the
conservative mp for northwest durham
that richard that is richard holden
who's backing vicious good morning to
you richard thank you for coming in this
morning so rishi is still in the lead
but people are coming up close behind
him there must be a bit of nervousness
now in the rishi campaign i think rich
is about as far ahead as he was after
the first round but obviously now moved
to over a hundred supporters from the
parliamentary party could it get to 120
to get into those final two places and
but i'm confident that over the next
couple of rounds we'll be able to
definitely make that threshold and get
richie into the final two because i
really think he's the best person place
to beat labour at the next general
election you know hold constituencies
like mine which were you know labor for
such a long time uh and we only took in
2019. yeah we'll come on to some of that
soon but let's just make sure he gets
there at this point so look where is he
going to get his extra votes from
because the the reporting would suggest
that the votes that are left are
probably going to go to the right of the
party which may go to list trust i think
we're going to see another couple of
rounds at least here and so i think we
should hopefully see some of those
people and i'll be having conversations
i'm sure a lot of my colleagues are
already supporting rishi as well we're
having those conversations uh over the
next few days to say you know come on
who do you really think is the best
person best place to beat kirstalmo and
stop that sort of lib dem labor possibly
backed up by the snp coalition after the
next general election my view is clear
it's somebody with a record of delivery
in government and somebody i think
really can take their country forward uh
but in a proper balanced and adult way
and i think that is rishi sooner i mean
that may be the feeling among mps and
among yourselves but um it's not the
feeling among the grassroots is it
because you see you'll have seen the
polls he's way behind to penny more than
he's behind even to tom tugan who's in
last place of the mp votes well i think
what we all know is that um rishi is a
very very well known uh character
everybody else at the moment you know
some of those people will not really be
household names outside westminster i
think that they've made that themselves
and most of them are quite good friends
of mine actually people like tom and but
i really think that as this race comes
down and we get into those final two
we've only been it's only just over a
week since the president
we've got weeks to go but if he's well
known then surely he should be doing
better with the the grassroots the party
doesn't seem to be doing i think it's
very easy to project whatever you like
on somebody who you don't know that well
you know it's like when you're starting
a new relationship you've got all these
ideas i've been married for 12 years
i don't know no idea if i started your
relationships
you can project whatever you want onto
somebody but actually over time things
develop and you start to think of what's
realistic what's in the good of the
country and i think that's what people
in my you know my constituency
rishi visited recently when an absolute
storm at a a flags factory and trying a
bit of saying with the seamstresses
understand small business because that's
his family background you know i i think
he he really will uh start to connect
and i hopefully we can move away and
offer a positive vision rather than this
sort of
conservative on conservative attacks
which i really don't like we will talk
about some of that in a moment i do want
to talk a little bit more about rishi
sooner i mean there is there are
questions
i think you would agree about his
decision-making because he obviously was
the chancellor he was firmly behind
boris johnson but there are now some
questions about when he decided that he
was going to try and go for the top job
is his integrity in question here at all
i really don't think so look i was on
boris's leadership campaign right from
the very start when forrest was six to
one to become prime minister and rishi
was uh you know on that from quite soon
after i was you know he really brought
over people like oliver dowden robert
generic during that leadership election
to really help push boris into pole
position has been behind him as long as
he possibly could all the way since then
things have changed since 2019 there's
those early days of early summer by this
time three years ago um and and we have
to accept that they have we now have to
accept that we're going to look forward
who's going to be the best person to
take on kids dama at the next general
election that's what i'm interested in
because i need to hold my seat in order
to deliver for people in my seat and
that's what i you know i'm saying to
that to colleagues across the country at
the moment and you know i think which is
leading in the polls and leading with
mps because they know he can be trusted
to deliver with a sensible plan against
mps do you think that the question about
the grassroots members is that is that
question about loyalty i think he does
feel like he stabbed reference in the
back a little bit no i don't think
anybody can suggest that he stabbed
bryce johnson in the back he was very
has been very upfront throughout this
entire situation he's backed the prime
minister all the way through the last
couple of years through some really
difficult decisions over cobid that
worked very closely together backed him
in support for ukraine over the last few
months as well um i don't think he'd be
a question of that but now we've got to
think about
looking forward what is the best for the
country and the conservative as as the
prime minister said you know
conservative mps in parliament already
made their decision um so we've now got
to accept that and move forward i mean
if he was to make to the final two and
then to the top job you you've mentioned
that you think he would be useful to
help you hold on to your seat uh in in
durham i mean do you think that's right
having a multi-billionaire
millionaire running the country is the
is the right person because you can see
where the attacks are going to come from
later so kirsten was already doing it at
pmq's and there's an attack ad out that
you would have seen of course
whether it's rishi sunak who's uh
wealthier than many of my constituents
or kierstarma who is far wealthier than
any of my constituents could ever dream
to be either what people i think are
really interested in is who's best for
them who's going to run the country
rishi's got a track record of supporting
working people in my constituency as
well during the pandemic the furlough
scheme saved you know millions of jobs
the the business loans saved thousands
of businesses probably hundreds of
businesses in my constituency alone and
we can see what he's been doing during
the you know following russia's invasion
of ukraine with those huge price packs
we've seen in oil gas food stuffs you
know there's cash going into the pockets
yes across the piece we've got 150
pounds for every household in bandai
today already gone through 400 quid
coming in october but also focus support
on those who really in need and when he
has had the ability to cut taxes and try
to drive that fuel duty which affects
all of my constituents because you know
um
driving is an absolute necessity for so
many of them and secondly raising the
threshold on national insurance which
really actually the people it impacts
best of all people earning under 36 000
pounds a year working hard for their
families in constituencies like mine i
mean just those the help it was was
leveled during the pandemic with
furlough and all that money that was
given out that is why he's been called
by some people a socialist i mean is
that a charge that you have any truck
with at all and what do you think your
constituencies constituency members
think about that sort of thing because
of course having all that money it's
great and it helped them out through the
pandemic but that's not gonna that's
where is it i think that's a bit of a a
total nonsense and uh i won't comment on
uh anonymous uh quotes in there i mean
we know who said it earlier anonymous
quotes in the press uh what what rishi
is interested in delivering is is a
strong economy and also providing
opportunity for people in constituencies
like mine you know
people are ambitious in places like
northwestern for themselves for their
families but also for that broader
community it's why they voted for change
at the last general election and i
really think that despite the challenges
we've faced over the last couple of
years with covert in the war in ukraine
the way she's going to be the best
person uh positioned to really deliver
that and help push that transformational
agenda forwards into the future he's
visiting places like concert he's
already helped me out
with within 100 days of becoming
chancellor he cancelled the eu's motor
homes tax rise you know that is that
that saves jobs directly in the heart of
my constituency uh i know he'll listen
to people like me and to constituents
and their voices from constituencies
like mine because he already has done
he's got a track record of doing it and
that's why i'm backing him to be prime
minister say listen to you will you tell
him to take part in sky news's debate on
the 19th of july well i'll make
representations on your behalf i'm
always happy too i hope so i mean it's a
good thing from state parliament isn't i
mean well he's taking it tonight and
he's taking part tonight uh and he's i
think he's taking part in another one
yeah but i will be more than happy to
lobby on your behalf please do ask him
too the 19th of july sky news can take
questions from the audience as well
brilliant okay well i will i will ask
him i will ask him we do appreciate that
thank you very much all right i
appreciate your time thank you for
coming in thank you
all right well let's uh speak to our
political correspondent robert powell in
just a few minutes but first here's a
reminder of how the process works to
elect the next conservative leader now
on uh monday there will be another round
of secret voting held that'll be the
third secret ballot the candidate with
the fewest votes will be eliminated
there'll be further ballots next week as
necessary until just two candidates
remain
the whole party membership will be
balloted on the final two with the new
party leader and our new prime minister
being named by the fifth of september
well our political correspondent robert
powell is here with us now rob good
morning to you so we've heard now from
richard holden and maria miller i mean
what are your thoughts on what they've
had to say about their respective uh
candidates i think you can see the
contours of this contest starting to
form now and it is still wide open there
is a path i think for potentially
everyone maybe with the exception of tom
toon had to make it to the final two
that said with rishi sunak i think now
on 101 votes he needs 19 more to
essentially get to a point where he can
feel confident of being on that final
ballot so whilst that could change and
there's a long way to go until those
final battles play out you i think it is
fair to assume that the most likely
outcome is that potentially he will be
one of the two names on the membership
and what we are starting to see this
morning is really the battle for who is
going to be that second name and that
seems to be really at its most fierce
between penny mordant and liz trust and
in some of the newspapers this morning
you are seeing i think an operation by
supporters of liz trust to try and um
kind of bring the right of the
conservative party behind her those that
are more in favor
of kind of [ __ ] tax cuts if i could
put it that way behind this trust so
you've got lord frost who used to be a
brexit minister in the government no
longer a minister now though writing a
very critical piece in the telegraph
saying why he's backing this trust but
also attacking penny morden saying he
worked with her in the cabinet office he
said she was absent on parade she shied
away from delivering tough messages on
the eu she wasn't accountable or visible
she didn't lead or stand up for the
country he had to be sacked and replaced
by i think he tried the excellent
michael ellis that is what lord frost is
claiming in response day maria miller
earlier take being rather more
diplomatic and measured in her words i
think but still essentially making the
jibe that this is a man that is not in
government anymore is not an mp no one's
voted for him and is joining this debate
from the outside which of course um he
is now look this is all to be expected
in a toy leadership race but i think
that criticism does speak to potentially
one of the weaknesses penny morden has
that she's a relative unknown people
aren't necessarily sure what she
believes in that's the challenge for her
i think in the coming days the risk for
liz trust is that if supporters
especially ones that aren't even mps
like lord frost continue to come out and
attack other candidates in such an
upfront way it potentially looks a
little bit petty so i would say still
all to play for and there could be big
changes especially with tv debates and a
weekend of newspapers to come absolutely
right we'll see where we are with this
on monday more really appreciate that
from you later okay let's take a look at
the morning sports news changes here
yeah lots going on in sport right now a
lot going on yesterday and so much more
to come today with 150th open
championship headed into day two
wow calm down johnny it's only a game
brought to you by vitality sharing the
benefits of healthy living
and it was all about this man rory
mcilroy sits just two shots off the lead
after the opening round of the 150th
open the northern irishman shot a round
of six underpass 66 as he made an
impressive start to his beard for a
fifth major
macaroon hold a 55-footer on his opening
hole and made three consecutive birdies
from the fourth to reach the turn in 32
mcelroy almost made eagle on the last
but settled for a birdie and a six-under
par 66
[Applause]
in contrast for tiger woods the 15-time
major champion carded a six over par
opening round his joint worst ever round
at the open this miss birdie part at the
18th summed up his day
but it's america's cameron young who
leads the way his opening round 64 is
the second lowest in open history at
saint andrews this birdie on the 18th
his eighth of the day on a bogey three
round
[Applause]
qriket now reece topley starred with the
ball with england dug in to level their
one day international series against
india with a hundred rung victory in the
second match at lords
topley took six for 24 the best figures
for england in the men's odi as the host
expertly defended 246.
to the women's euros england will be
looking to make it three wins out of
three tonight when they take on northern
ireland in their final group game at
saint mary's
in last night's games france clinched a
place in the knockout stages with a 2-1
win over belgium this goal by um bog
batty before half-time proven to be the
winner
earlier iceland held italy to a one-all
draw leaving both sides needed to win
their final game to have a chance of
reaching the quarter-final carolina leah
v harm's daughter's strike gave iceland
the lead
but an equaliser from valentina
bergomaski after halftime earned italy
their first point in the tournament they
face belgium on monday iceland take on
france
cycling now britain tom peacock won his
maiden tour de france stage in style
with a solo victory atop the iconic
altuz
peacock and four-time tour champion
chris froome were part of a five-man
breakaway during stage 12.
the yorkshire man at the age of 22
becoming the youngest winner and only
the second brit to win on the outdoors
jonas finger gore retains the yellow
jersey
that's all for the sports for now will
be back in the next hour don't forget
you can catch day two of the 150th open
championship live now on sky sports golf
handball
handball
handball ref handball riff
okay more now on the race to become the
next lead of the conservative party and
of course the next prime minister let's
get the view of what grassroots
conservative groups want i'm joined by
joseph robinson the director of orthodox
conservatives joseph good morning to you
thanks for being with us we'll come on
to who you want to be leader soon but
just how has the how has the grassroots
in your opinion sort of been viewing the
way that this contest has gone so far
it's been interesting it's been just as
divided i think at that level as it is
right at the top um and i think what
people are seeing now is that candidates
are revealing more and more about
themselves as we get down towards the
final three and people's positions are
shifting um i think as other candidates
fall behind
um many people whose loyalties you
wouldn't have expected to lie in those
areas are now falling behind because
they just don't see their candidate as
viable any longer in terms of
winnability we want to see about this
push from the right of the party for
this trust to be the one sure well i
think that's very much um a
a kind of concerted effort to rebrand
this trust i mean of course at one point
she was a remainer uh and in fact lib
dem at one point in her career and of
course has now shifted to be
sugar-coated as the brexit darling and i
don't buy that i don't think a lot of
the membership really buy that i think
that's more an internal push to
reposition her do you think the
memberships see that do you think they
100 i don't i don't think i don't think
they're as stupid as some people would
like to think um and i think they're
going to be in for a very unpleasant
shock if if liz is definitely the brexit
candidate in that final two um yeah all
right so who who did the membership one
do you think in your pocket we've seen
penny more than like way out ahead some
of those polls yeah sure so i think the
the battle is between the more liberal
mordent and then the more conservative
pad not i i think that's the clear split
now um i think you've got rishi and
trust as the establishment and i think
they're going to be more of the same
from the memberships view um we've been
calling for a long time to have
primaries to this because i thought it
was the only way that we could actually
see these candidates in action see what
you know find out some of the dirt on
each of them and have them grill each
other for once but
as it is we're whittling down whittling
down and suddenly people are beginning
to realize it's going to be stolen all
over again stolen is one way of putting
obviously we don't want to get too close
to an american style system we're trying
to stay away from that so who are you
supporting then so i was behind
braverman um i i'm in a little bit of a
quandary now because i'm backing kemi
but obviously swell has gone and and
packed truss as well yeah what is that
about how does can we feel about that do
we know uh so i think what comey didn't
realize is that uh listen to ella had a
two-way pledge with that so that's being
honored
um however they had actually assured
exactly exactly so if if it had fallen
the other way uh we could actually see
trust falling behind sowella and kemi i
think but as it is kemi is the
standalone
viable socially conservative right of
the party sort of candidate which is
i think where the memberships are
leaning towards now for sure yeah i mean
the membership maybe leading towards but
how i mean if she was to get i mean and
it's his long shot if she could get to
the top job but how would she think
she'd fair in the country some of those
views i don't think would be liked by
many yeah i mean i think certainly from
an economic perspective um you have to
look at what the red will really want to
see which is internal growth i think
morden has a history not only of not
being able to define what a woman is and
all the big issues that everyone's been
discussing but also
of course of looking at sending a lot of
foreign aid she was in charge of dfid
um and and that's a big issue it's
similar to the situation with rishi i
don't think people forget uh all this
fiscal juggling too quickly um i mean
he's been called a socialist as i said
it's just a little sure sure sure so are
you behind that i i think i if you look
at economic policy it's been to the left
of blair now for
however many years in in the
conservatives argument we had to deal
with the pandemic and we have but that
hasn't stopped that's that that hasn't
stopped you know we're out of crisis
time and we're still spending uh we're
still borrowing yeah i'm sorry we have
to stop i couldn't keep talking to you
all morning but really lovely to have
you here thank you joseph